well
let me welcome everybody to session nine
of classic metal class we're kind of
following
up with our last session which was on
1970s
american medal and you know there were
quite a few bands that we talked about
and some of them centered around
new york some of them la and this time
we're going to be digging
right into the la scene and
i i picked the the terms um sunset strip
and la connection
quite deliberately the sunset strip as
we're going to talk about was
a major venue in a lot of different ways
for the development of heavy metal in
the 1980s in in america actually going
back to the 70s but but then continuing
on through an la connection if you if
you haven't heard it is a really great
rainbow song off of the album long live
rock and roll and now you could say well
why would an english essentially english
band with fronted by an american singer
from
new you know the new york area rather
than la why would they be talking about
la connection and it is kind of a song
about you know having sex
and stuff right but it's but it's also
about
what la represented and the more that
scott and i have been
digging into this and kicking ideas
around and then looking people up the
more
clear it is how there wasn't just an
la connection you can call it like an la
network of connections
all these interesting bits of musical
history and you know you might even look
at them as trivia when you see them like
in a wikipedia article
but they add up to something and there's
a couple things that i want to say
sort of by by prep work and scott feel
free to jump in
at any moment by the way i'll let me
introduce
since there may be some new viewers to
this this is my my friend and colleague
scott chirulli from the berkeley school
of music
practicing guitarist a guitar professor
he's done gigs and studio work with all
sorts of people
three albums of his own and a
fellow metal head since child childhood
right
uh so he and i kick a lot of these ideas
around behind the scenes
um and actually how many years we've
been
talking about this half a decade at
least right
yeah you're right yeah good
six years yeah yeah
so so in any case um there were a few
things i just wanted to mention and
again scott feel free to
jump in on any of these so
when we talk about la metal
in the 1980s there was really an
explosion right in the early to
mid 80s and something similar is
happening to
what we call the new wave of british
heavy metal which i would say included
more bands than the la
scene and we've talked about the new
wave of british heavy metal before
interestingly if you look on like metal
forums there are there are quite a few
people who will say
yeah new wave of british heavy metal
that was definitely heavy metal
la metal uh maybe more hard rock than
than metal and then there's other people
who jump in and they say no no it's a
different
kind of metal there's a different scene
that's going on
and i think there's there's a bit of
permeation
uh between the two of them because some
of those new wave of british heavy metal
bands if they made it big enough
they would tour and they'd hit la um
some of them like def leppard
got tagged or tarred however you want to
put it as being
a two american band because they're you
know effectively relocating
to to the states and and sounding more
like american stuff i think there really
is a distinctive
sound and scott's going to help us out
with a lot of this stuff as we get into
the sonic
landscape of this um the other thing
that i want to
mention is that so donna weinstein who i
think a lot of people have heard me talk
about before she's got this this really
great
book called heavy metal a cultural
sociology
and it's kind of a landmark study early
on
now i i'm not sure i buy into this uh
entirely
but she breaks down early metal genres
and early we mean 1970 to
through the 19 early 1980s before we
have this spiraling off in the late 80s
into all these different
subgenres that a lot of younger people
you know
that's the lens through which they see
metal at the time that she's writing she
says listen there's basically three main
genres
there's this middle of the road that we
can call classic heavy metal
power metal so a lot of speed metal fits
in there
uh we're thinking about bands like judas
priest iron maiden
uh ronnie james dio is in his solo stuff
rainbow would kind of fit in there
deep purple black sabbath right and then
on the other side and this is this is
particularly important for
the la stuff is what she she's willing
to call it
metal light we could call it pop
metal glam metal whatever you want to
call it and she says
you know i'm not i'm not making a value
judgment here i'm just
sort of expressing the value judgment
that a lot of other metal fans who are
further along
the spectrum would say about this but
that was the stuff that that
probably was the most successful in
terms of like
getting into the mtv sphere um
selling records you know if you think
about like in in the 1980s
uh motley crue was a huge band you know
and they're they're a good
exemplification that poison would be
further
in that that territory right um
and you know when we talk about hair
metal we're really talking about
both of those segments both the classic
metal stuff that's sort of middle of the
road
and the the glam metal and everything in
between
you know and then we have something that
we're going to talk about in in a
separate session
she talks about thrash and nowadays i
think we'd say extreme metal all those
things that turned into big genres like
black metal
um uh you know all the niche things
you know like pirate metal um
it's starting to appear at that time but
the things where
it's it's a rejection of that
ethos that's associated with with
pop metal or glam metal or whatever you
want to call it the softer stuff and
they make it harder and crunchier and
faster
so metallica mega death you know classic
thrash bands like that would fit in
there
you could say that that some of the more
mainstream metal bands as they get into
the 90s they start moving
in that direction as well let's not be
not uh
anthrax by the way who i think was yeah
west west
or east coast band um right and uh
i mean there's i think we're going to do
a whole thing just on thrash
down the line because there's such an
interesting story to be
told there right yeah so big time
now what scott what do you what do you
make of this division
you know into these three broad classes
of
you know on the one extreme you got the
sort of thrash we're going to wear
you know we're not going to wear spandex
we're going to wear just blue jeans and
band t-shirts and we're not going to
puff up our hair it's just going to lay
flat you know and we're going to play
harder and heavier and faster
uh not like those as they would say not
like those posers over there
who are in you know in the in the 1980s
are much more successful you know
both in terms of like filling up
auditoriums and in
selling records and getting on mtv uh
you know bands like motley crue or
poison or
even rant it kind of fits in there right
and then we've got this big mainstream
where you've got bands that aren't
really
caring about that and are probably a bit
heavier
um like iron maiden or do
one one of the bands that we're going to
talk about from the la seen
armored saint would fit in there you
know what do you make of this is it is
it too simplistic to have this
three-part distinction does it leave out
too much
you know i no i don't think it's too
simplistic it's it's worth pointing out
because i think
um you and i uh being in
the scene in real time as it was it was
evolving you know i remember the first
time i heard
uh metallica's kill them all yeah and
you know
okay well you know first of all we said
ac dc just made noise
now it's like you know but now ac dc's
sounds rock and roll next to this and we
probably agree that
easy but um yeah as as um
bands like metallica came out and
they're heavier and faster
um then what we saw was people
i always take the the test of the the
audience
so like if you remember in school we
might start with
say a band like a classic band like uh
uh deep purple okay rock and roll heavy
metal arguably of the time
remember we have to like we have to take
what what the time is but then as this
new music came out
you saw some people go this way yeah
they
they related more to the if you want to
call it thrash or speed
and then the ones that kind of went here
it's like well they're still heavy
guitars
but there's some melodies going on like
you know
steve piercy wasn't a great singer but
round and round when that came out
i mean i remember my deadhead friends
like having their books remember you you
write your favorite band they would
cross
grateful dead and they put rap forever
interesting
so what i found is and i don't know what
you found
i found that um as new music came out
some was i remember like when motley
crue shout out to the devil came out
that some of my friends were like oh my
god i bought it i listened to it i'm a
die hard and like i listened to it every
day and i had it i liked it but like it
became that they were like very
obsessed with this you know heavy sound
yeah
guitars so i think
you know just in our society of
high school you know we didn't have the
internet to like look at boards but you
would see people and
me and i always joke about the the the
jean jacket test who makes it on the
jean jacket
yeah and but you would see the people
with
only speed metal bands you wouldn't see
triumph the canadian band but you
wouldn't see triumph on a
on somebody that had like anthrax and
metallica and they were
they were heavier and um
much more of a bunch of bad boys or you
know zebra would be another band like
that you know they were
when you talk about metal light i think
zebra is a perfect exemplification of
that you know
metal light is funny because that's um
is that derogatory i don't know
i think it is derogatory the people who
are labeling other bands
that way uh right but you know um
zebra's stuff was good triumph stuff is
is great
um oh god yeah hurricane would be
an la band that would kind of fit that
mold i think
you know and who is the guitarist for
hurricane um
oh i don't remember um and i was just
looking them up the
the other day uh i'm blanking but i'll
remember but i mean a lot of these
earlier bands like that
you know it's like uh take doug aldrich
that was
wasn't white snake but then before that
he was a doe
before that uh what was his band um
in the 80s so doug aldrich has like this
whole
la you know he would go from band to
band and then start getting
you know picked up by people like yeah
theo and so um it's almost like building
up a cv
right in a way oh exactly playing with
these different bands you know
but here's what's interesting something
that maybe we should talk about at some
point is
that these let's just say guitarist for
example
was every gig they did pretty much the
same
genre like would doug aldrich be invited
into a band similar to metallica
i mean i'm sure he could play it but
like do they stick to
i'm trying to think if they're like more
chameleons or they bring what their
sound is to the band
you know what i mean so it's like yeah
so do
that i mean this is this is like a total
digression but if you think about
the the and not just in the la
scene but but more generally the
challenge
of stepping into the shoes of some other
guitarist
um so let's let's take for example
um motorhead right so you start out with
fast eddie clark
who actually is a replacement for uh the
pink fairies guy uh larry wallace right
larry wallace drops out and and fast
eddie clark is the guy
with um lemmy and phil taylor for quite
a while
until he quits after iron fist and now
now they start looking for other
guitarists and the person they settle on
is brian robertson from thin lizzie
and um it's very you know it's a
different kind of sound i mean there are
some similarities
in that you can you can and you know
more about this
you know from a sonic perspective than i
do but you can hear some similarities
between
robertson and and uh fascity clark
you know they're both using kind of a
reverby sort of sort of sound with a lot
of sustain
they're they're both kind of lyrical in
the way that they they solo
um but it is different and then
robertson only sticks around for one
album and after that
it's now two guitars um and they they
move forward from
from there every time you gotta step
into somebody else's shoes
that's that's kind of a uh
you know a tricky thing right how much
are you
how much how much of their space are you
taking up you know is there enough room
for you to develop develop on your own
you know and you know um first of all
you came up with probably
the best example i could think of from
thin lizzy to motorhead
yeah so now we're talking those are i
would
separate those genres i don't know about
you like finn lindsay's not
thin lizzie is one of those bands that
often gets grandfathered in is heavy
metal but they're not heavy enough
they're not heavy metal
i mean hollywood that's a great song i
mean boys are back in town
um they always remind me of the reeling
in the years lick the steely dan tune
it was kind of like um and it was they
were a rock band
and uh there was and phil linette's
vocals weren't
heavy metal vocals you know they were
that's right yeah
and that's one of the things like the
singers jeff tate versus that
um lemmy you know if we want to look for
like
things closer to the la scene right
we've got think about ozzie's band
he poaches randy rhodes from quiet riot
right which leads to the dissolution of
the early quiet riot band so now you've
got one guy there
and then randy rhodes dies then we get
we get jk lee coming in
um you know having to step in to
randy rhodes position in one of the most
popular bands
of the world at the time i would i would
say that had to be pretty tough
[Music]
yeah i mean you know for him if you
think about it um
he had to be post tony iomie in some
respects
yeah well you know there's there's an
even more convoluted connection there
right because
jk lee is coming out of roughcut which
is being managed at that time by
wendy dio yes and there's already a tiff
between you know ozzy and ronnie james
deal
mainly on ozzy's part because he didn't
like the fact that you know
anybody became the singer for black
sabbath after him and he said a lot of
derogatory things you know about about
rodney james dio
and so you know i think there's already
a background of some some stuff going on
there but i mean imagine
having to step into the shoes of one of
those guitars and both randy rhodes and
j.k lee um make
they're different guitarists and they
make really different contributions
on those first four early albums you
know
uh another thing to think about just as
and i play this game with myself my
whole life
is especially the older i get where yeah
i i
i develop my own sound more and more and
i'm like well
if let's say um
if if white snake called or or let's
just say
no okay let's say let's say if um rat
called
because warren d martini's not in the
band anymore yeah my first thing would
be go
would just say can i do those solos
justice because he's got a whole
different time feel than me
i mean yes i could probably play them
but
in the way you know i say actually a
good a good
place to take a pause and talk about
something we were going to get into a
little bit later on
but so you bring up this term time feel
and this is something that you and i
were talking about earlier
this week as as something distinctive to
a guitarist almost part of their their
character
you could say right exactly so so
when it comes to a solo i mean you see
this on youtube all the time right
i'm i'm gonna do you know van halen's
eruption and here's how you do it note
for note or
like jakey lee actually i think got on a
video one time and he's like a lot of
people screw up bark at the moon
here's the intro riff here's how it
actually get gets done right
so you can play the notes and anybody
can play the notes think about like on a
piano right
you can put your fingers in the right
place but that's not
that's not the same thing as playing
jakey lee's solo on bark at the moon or
um pick whoever else you like you know
um
so in music this is something
interesting that i make a a
i kind of um exemplify
the whole thing so we have something
that if uh now with notation program
um in midi and everything that if i
wrote the notes correctly if i
transcribed the jakey lee solo and
transcribed it
perfectly correctly into the notation
you can hit the spacebar
and the um you'll hear a piano or a
pseudo guitar sound play the solo note
for note at the right tempo
but it's stiff it's like
so yeah that might be the solo but it's
not the solo
because uh there's three things actually
this is kind of a thing that i've gone
by there's three things that
that separate um that give people their
own voice
one is their time you know like eddie
van halen nobody
has touched the beat at solo correctly i
mean people can copy it close
but his swagger and the way he plays and
then
you know it's very greasy um you know i
know on the
even you know jennifer batten who's an
amazing guitar player and
she played the solo note for note but it
wasn't it wasn't eddie
so there's something missing there right
yeah it might not be something missing
there's something else there that's not
eddie's thing
yeah and and then the second thing is
pitch organization what i mean is
if you have a c major scale um we all
have access to that but what makes
what i would do with a c major scale and
what you would do with the c major scale
differently
we would organize the pitches in our own
way maybe your interval
uh you're interested in different
intervals or
so pitch organization meaning how we
play things together so
jakey lee would do these solos but like
he'd be using the scale entirely
different than randy rhodes did
so and that's the second thing uh and
the third thing is sound
so um even take this is not metal
um but even take like robert smith from
the cure
you know when that chord hits who's
playing that because of his sound or the
edge
another non-metal but like you know like
uh zach wilde when you hear those
pinch harmonics the way he does them you
know it's zack wilde
you know i i read something really
interesting uh recently about
the two kiss guitarists the original
kiss guitars because of course you know
we also have like mark st
john and all these other people uh tommy
thayer
you know um and uh
it was paul stanley and he was in an
interview and he was talking about
ace freely and he and you know ace
freely
um apparently he claims that you know he
never had any lessons
and and just sort of like learned to
play guitar on his own
and it was plausible because you know
like i i'd never actually like learned
how to play the banjo properly
and my my fretting and fingering is not
what it ought to be
and apparently that's what has really
has done
throughout his career he just happens to
be good enough that
he can make sub-optimal ways of holding
the guitar
work for him and paul stanley said that
one of the things he noticed about ace
freely
was when it came to putting tremolo
on things you know or or vibrato or
something
yeah yeah yeah he so paul stanley would
do it with his hand
right he said that ace freely would do
it with his whole
arm and the way he held the guitar he
would shake the guitar
rather than doing it on the string and
it would accomplish the same thing it's
not not a very effective or efficient
way of doing it but you know
some if you're ace freely you can make
it work for you you know
and i think there's a lot of there's
probably and you you tell me whether i'm
right or wrong about this when it comes
to how a guitarist or
a bassist or a drummer approaches their
their thing or even a singer and how
they're using the
the vocal chords and stuff like that we
all have our own
quirks in how we approach the instrument
you know like
me being taller than you if i was if i
was remotely as talented as you and i
had those guitars that are behind you
i would still play them a bit
differently just based on the fact that
i'm six foot three and i'd be like
curled around it um maybe even like you
know i remember when we saw
raven you know we were down in new york
at the gramercy
and um john gallagher was great
guitarist
um he's you know he's like a lot of us
gained a lot of weight in in
midlife and he had he was like the
guitar was like
almost you know a little thing inside of
his big body
and it looked like he was almost like
squeezing the notes out of it like you
would squeeze
tooth toothpaste from uh you know
a toothpaste uh what do we call the
sleeve or container right
great right and and it was the raven
songs but you would think okay it's
probably going to be somewhat different
playing than when he was 20 years old
um you know playing with his his older
brother mark
in in these british pubs or something
like that right
yeah um just to go back um i'm trying to
keep place because you started with this
great ace freely story
i want to go back to that for a second
if you don't mind okay um bruce kulick
was he an la guy do you know if you i
think
i want to say that he was from new york
yeah mark st
john was an la guy i'm pretty sure but i
remember
um what's that
wasn't isn't tommy thayer from l.a
uh very yeah very likely and he was the
he was aces tech i think oh right
and so ace wasn't showing up to giggs
and one night it's like well you're
gonna have to suit up like ace and go
out there because
tommy there was in a kiss tribute band
or you knew all the songs
yeah but something very interesting i
didn't want to leave this point yet
um so everybody's like well ac doesn't
really know what he's doing he's like
you know it's a bunch of chuck berry
licks it's you know this
but mark uh um
bruce kulick when he came in well here's
this of the times guy that was tapping
and
and doing the stuff and you know
technically a much better guitar player
than ace but here's the thing
all the fans go it's not ace he can't
he sounds bad doing the a solos it
doesn't work
because ace has this swagger had his own
way like you said
he would have his own wave to get the
vibrato he would have his own
that he's figured out and so i think
that's a
going back to the whole thing about
stepping in someone else's shoes well he
was obviously hired to be the new 80s
guitar player
and but still when they did the classic
kiss stuff fans complained
like no can't do it like ace you know
you know you're technically a better
guitar player
um everybody said well you sound great
on the stuff
the albums you were on but not uh
not on the ace stuff so that's that
always struck me as interesting because
then you gain more respect
for the person before yeah
realizing um that you can't entirely
replicate it i mean
so we're way off topic here but let me
ask you one
question about that if you're if you're
in that sort of dilemma then
are you better off trying to do
your best to the the solo that somebody
else has
originated or
should you just maybe insert your own
solo i would
souls were part of the song so you
couldn't do that okay
so like if i joined um if i joined
rapt yeah obviously warren d martini
solos
are part of the song i mean they're epic
yeah yeah
um so if i went and just improvised my
own thing i think
even as a fan um i'd be disappointed
because even if it's
somebody at the show and be like what
the hell is this guy doing yeah exactly
you know like um i remember what's his
name
uh he's a british guitarist did the
roger waters wall tour
and one of the things he said is he he
stands on the top of this huge wall way
across
way above the crowd and he has to play
the comfortably numb solo
and he said it it was the biggest
pressure for me because i know people
spent hundreds of dollars just to hear
that solo
yeah and he said if i screw it up i've
ruined somebody's night
because you know so here here we are
just now the whole l.a scene they all
play so different
they're all like exploring their own
things um they go do their thing but
but we also just back to their they're
still uh joining different bands or
they're into the same band
or they were in this band in the past
and did a project in the future
we have the scene in la
um that's actually a scene people were
hanging i get much like the jazz
musicians of
new york city in the 50s and 60s they
all jammed together
after hours you know they would so
i guess these people like hung out at
the rainbow they drink together
they go uh there's all the stories of
them going to the studio and hearing the
new tracks
um yeah so
actually this is a good good place to
get back on on on track
um we we worked out as we were prepping
for this
10 bands that we thought were most
emblematic of
the spectrum of what was going on in l.a
new bands that some of them started in
the 70s actually some of them started
very early in the 70s but they made it
big
particularly by the the 80s or if they'd
made it big in the 70s like van halen
they made it way way bigger
by the 80s and so um
i'm going to give you the 10 bands and
then we'll tell you a little bit why
you know for those of you who might not
be as familiar with
you know 1980s metal why we picked them
so
van halen motley crew rat
dawkin quiet riot wasp poison
lizzie borden armored saint and syria
ungl
so van halen and and uh quiet riot they
were they were on the scene
in the 70s late 70s starting to make it
big on van halen's part um you know
there's that old joke about big in japan
and that's the way quiet riot
unfortunately was
since their stuff wasn't um it wasn't
available except in japan
and then their band fell apart um rant
uh you know was you could say it had its
origins in this band mickey rat
that jakey lee was in along with stephen
percy
um dawkin was uh that can actually
contain some members early on who would
go on to rat
and um dawkin was starting to make it
big
in the late 70s and then and then you
know obviously made it really big in the
80s when they
i remember a friend of mine
when i was in high school who saw them
in crocus
and this had been about maybe 1985 and
dawkin was opening for crocus
and that was kind of the death knell for
croakus as a band
because doc can just you know you never
want the opening band to blow you off
the stage and that's what happened
you know uh people were like buoying
crocus
after that i guess they were kind of low
energy dawkin was at the top of their
game
with that you know creative tension
between
uh don dawkin as a singer and george
lynch who apparently didn't like each
other
and then you know jeff pilsen was on
base um
so you know really dynamic group and
then you know wasp
right wasp has got a really interesting
back story and they're not
making that they're they're they're
appearing to come on the scene for
like me reading circus or hit parade or
stuff like that
like they're coming after motley crue
and rat but actually
the guys who were in wasp um there was a
lot of
you know la back story to that with with
other bands
and blackie lawless goes all the way
back to you know the new york scene
that he comes out of in the the 70s um
poison i think a lot of people are
familiar with that not you know
not least because of um uh
i don't know what brett michael's and uh
his
second career as a reality star
oh my gosh that oh and um
actually a bunch of them cece deville
had his own show oh that's right yeah
yeah yeah
um a lot of these people what do they
call that the
seven steps to hell like as a as a um
celebrity right you know first really he
did the celebrity boxing and
danny danny
no no i don't think you're talking about
uh from the partridge family right right
so he's boxing uh vanilla ice and like
it's like they start to do the reality
shows because their careers
so i think they're called the seventh
grade steps to hell
and that's that's funny because
bringing up reality shows um andy was
just
mentioning to me oh andy says bonaduce
uh so
thank you yeah andy was just uh
mentioning to me that gene simmons was
on the apprentice and he did
he was on the apprentice and i was like
well it's because you know two big egos
and that's the best way the nicest way
to describe them aren't going to get
along all that well you know
well here's the thing they did and i i
watched some of them i watched the gene
simmons ones
and uh for those of you that don't know
about the show
consider yourself lucky but basically
donald trump and his character would be
like you're going to start a lemonade
stand and whoever
wins and like you've got to fire someone
you know so
the whole episode with gene simmons like
he was crushing it his team
because gene simmons and i don't know
how much this of this stuff was scripted
but
gene was a genius marketer and so he was
crushing the other team then they have
to
so anyways i think something came up
where kiss was gonna do a tour
so all of a sudden
um they do an episode and gene simmons
pretty much intentionally throws it but
i mean we're not supposed to think that
and there's an embarrassing scene at the
end where donald trump is across the
stage
the the desk from him and he's like you
know what you did was stupid that's not
like you and gene simmons was like yep i
know
then the uncomfortable part was donald
trump goes
am i the best and genius of those yeah
you're the greatest he goes you're the
greatest you're the greatest
you're one of the greatest marketers and
it became this whole this
angry back and forth of no you're better
no you're better so it was kind of like
the saving grace ducking out of the
episode
you made a mistake you're fired and
that that's a that stuck with me about
how they were like we got to write this
in we got to save face for gene simmons
uh now but you also have to stroke my
ego
and i'll stroke yours and we'll we'll
argue over who's
the brilliant one yeah that's far off
topic
well andy points out that they got along
but gene simmons didn't do well
with helping others um
you know i could i could i could see
that we're we're actually going to talk
a bit more about him
later on when we talk about management
and and producing
it's kind of a weird thing i mean yeah
would you want
gene simmons as your backer
you know how much creative control would
you retain
as opposed to him you know doing sort of
like being like a steamroller you know
and and uh i mean if you're the kind of
passive
person right you'd be like yeah let him
manage it he knows what he's doing you
know
um but i i think if if you're already
kind of uh
you've got a big picture of where you
want to go with your band i don't know
that you'd want gene simmons
as the manager you know that would be
great um
i'm sure nobody would go on uh on record
on saying it wasn't
but like you know we were talking about
the keel album he produced i think um
the right to rock was the album and
um personally i mean i love gene simmons
he's
as far as it'd be him being bigger than
life rockstar
you know you know fire that's all great
stuff and
you know um there's actually
footage not to to go off uh
there's four hours of footage from the
mid 80s of kiss backstage
there's no women back there there's only
soda
nobody was drinking and the whole time
he's all business saying
people paid good money you can't have
black on black so the lighting guy would
have to go
and it was really i didn't watch the
whole four hours but i did did start to
get into it where
these guys were all business so
i would think that gene simmons let's
say he was a backer an investor
yeah um or a producer
um i you know i i don't know
how great effective a bursary is but i'm
not i'm not suggesting he wouldn't be
good at it you know i don't i don't but
it would be a gene simmons production
is what i'm what i'm saying and so if
you're
you know so let's take keel right if
you're ron keel
and you're kind of an up-and-coming
um act and you've got some
some stuff behind you because you've
been in a couple other bands
that that were pretty successful before
that
and you've got a vision for what you
want can you get a big personality
like gene simmons to go with it or is it
going to be
more what he wants wants you to look
like
you know and thinks is appropriate for
the time you know
i mean it could it could actually if if
you're let's say you're
like a mid-range thing and you've got
somebody like a gene simmons or
a ronnie james dio and wendy dio you
know sort of a
a team like that helping you out
that could actually be very effective um
here's here's another way of putting it
so another person
who did a lot of management obviously
sharon osbourne right
and she wasn't just managing ozzy she
was also managing
other bands in the la area and the
question we can ask
is with ronnie james dio and wendy dio
on one side where they're
you know i i would trust them if i had a
band i
oh i agree yeah and and uh sharon
osbourne on the other who i wouldn't
trust with anything
where would gene simmons who did play a
big big role in the la
scene where would he fit would he be
like right in the middle
would he be more on on dio's side would
he be more on sharon osborne's side
you know well okay so let's this is
fascinating so deal
would be brutally honest
uh he would just be you know uh the
vocal don't do that
sing this you know he'd be very brutally
honest but like
i think he'd probably explain what's
going wrong too yeah oh yeah
you look at his interviews you know he
very thoughtful
um not blustering at all very blunt
but you know the things that people
needed to hear at the time
so dio's coming from uh let's make this
music good
but aaron osborne is about well
i'm here to make money and maybe even
screw you out of money during this
process
and you know she's notorious for having
younger people sign
bad deals yeah um well look what
happened to jakey lee now
you go to gene simmons well now you're
coming now you've got an ego
so i think with all three of them you
know you have somebody that's like will
stab you in the back at any second to
get some extra money then you have dio
who i would
you know if i ever had the opportunity
to work with him and
and wendy yeah his wife yeah and wendy
is um
and she's always done great by him and
you know you don't hear about wendy
being a terror to people
it's always sharon yeah um but um
i thought you're gonna choose ego which
is um
gene simmons not being brutally honest
but being
because i said so i i get
i get the feeling it'll be like you know
you know this is what rock and roll is
you don't know what rock and roll is
were you were you in uh were you and
kiss in the 70s
how many albums have you sold you know
yeah
yeah
um which which could be effective for a
band that just wants
uh somebody to come in and sort of like
fill in all the gaps you know
um i'm curious how that record ended up
doing
oh that would be something interesting
to you like in terms of how it charted
and how many how it started how the tour
went yeah you know did
did now i know a guy i know was in a
band called new england in boston
and paul stanley produced their 1979
album
and i see him a lot of times and he's
always like i mean
paul didn't really do anything he was
just there because of his name
he didn't really do give much input um
and it was kind of like so his name
would be on because they they had one
huge hit in the late
70s okay um but he's you know
paul i would prefer though but paul's a
great songwriter
you know if you look at the paul stanley
song so yeah
it's interesting you got to think of the
scene in la on how these people work
together you know did they
go out and do like songwriting sessions
of stuff we've never heard
like after the rainbow a few drinks you
know why don't you go back to my studio
let's jump into that aspect of it then
all
you know i mentioned earlier that
there's a lot of interconnections
going on and this is kind of interesting
too from a
let's call it a phenomenological
perspective coming from our experience i
think that both scott
and i can say as kids who are like
you know hearing metal in the 70s and
then like really getting into it in the
80s in our our teen years
um there wasn't any like great awareness
that there is a distinctive
la scene you know we're listening to
bands
like you mentioned ac dc so ac dc even
though they're not
they're arguably a metal band in some
respects but not really
right you know would they be on the jean
jacket would they be on the stuff that
you're you're
uh yes along with
ozzy osbourne because he had a cool logo
uh
dio of course um black sabbath
motorhead you know uh and then you know
rat motley crew they'd all be kind of
mixed in together indiscriminately and
it's not like we had a
it's not like we were engaging in
musicology at the time and were like
well you've
what you've got to understand is that
the you know the new york scene is
different
we were just a bunch of kids listening
to whatever we could hear and there was
just one big
genre of heavy metal as opposed to like
new wave or punk or pop or country
or you know pick whatever else you liked
and then and then things started to
differentiate where we'd be like yeah
thrash mu thrash is kind of different
than this this pop you know more poppy
stuff that we're hearing here and then
like you would watch
mtv when we could get it or vh1 and see
the videos and be like wow that
that band you know they really look
different than than this other band over
there
right so this this whole notion of like
the l.a scene was something that i think
we didn't we didn't have a lot of
insight into and how could we you know
we were just a bunch of kids
right i was getting most of my
information about these bands from
reading
the articles that made it into circus or
hit parader you know
you know me too i've ever been at the
grocery store you know trying to
grocery cart with my mom you know yeah
yeah or the drugstore
the drugstore of course so so this scene
um we're going to try to describe it and
what was
oh andy says def leppard was fun to
write on those folders as well yeah yeah
i agree we could actually do a whole
thing on like banned logos
sometime actually that's that's that's
actually kind of cool yeah so go ahead
i'm sorry yeah well so so that i think
we can identify a number of different
factors that came together
for la specifically and and some of
these go beyond
the music scene i mean la had hollywood
right and you've got this this um
long-standing
dynamic of people coming to hollywood
trying to make it big hoping that you
know the
the proverbial brass ring will turn out
to be gold
usually not making it right but they're
going to try to do it and then they
often get sucked into these these studio
systems that are there
la was also a mecca for things like new
religions
you know in religious studies there's a
lot of stuff that comes out of la and
it's not all like new agey
things either i mean that's where the
azusa street revival happened with
pentecostalism
you know there's there's a lot of like
things kind of
boiling up within la going way way back
and then if we think about the music
scene
right la becomes this weird kind of
mecca where you've got
you've got people who grow up in the la
scene and they can hear
pretty you know interesting innovative
music happening
there's record companies there although
also you know in in new york
um and then there's all these people who
flock in
trying to make it big including even
bands like cinderella was a philadelphia
band
they had to go out to l.a because that's
that's where the action was
um and then you've got all these other
people who are going to play a major
major role we talked about gene simmons
we talked about ronnie james dio
uh i think scott may have mentioned you
know let lemmy of motorhead was you know
sort of a fixture at the
the rainbow um there's all this talent
and not just talent in terms of sheer
musical talent
but talent in terms of figuring out like
what works in the music business
how to put bands together how to produce
things how to connect people up
that's spending time in la
and some of that is due to like just the
way taxes worked you know
bands like black sabbath you know
in the 80s tony oh me at least is
spending a lot of time
out in l.a in part because you know
the british taxes were high you know
that's
effectively located right what a great
wow this is fantastic right so that
makes sense
british bands ending up or yeah ending
up in l.a or stopping off
you know like if if you're going to be
on the west coast
then you're going to hang out in la and
you're going to drink at the rainbow
or or you know uh the whiskey a go-go or
whatever
and and you're going to meet all these
these people and you're gonna have
people coming up to you
like hey man i recognize you from this
or that you're you're so cool i want to
be
where you are today and i think what
you've got going on it's sort of like
when we talked about the new wave of
british heavy metal
the fact that there were you know new
record labels coming about like you know
neat records
and um you know all these pubs that
people could play in
and and other kinds of venues and then
they'd hear
other people's sounds they'd go to each
other's shows i think something like
that you can say is happening
in la it's also happening in new york
right and it's not happening
in too many other places in the us
until much later but la and new york so
la becomes like a
major cultural cauldron for heavy metal
to evolve with it
and something um that goes along with
this
so um i had mentioned this to you
earlier uh before we started the show
that there's definitely an la sound yeah
so talk about that a bit more
that's really important um
well there's a few things one of the
real important things is kind of a
practical
um observation so
in la um all the musicians
uh it was such a hot spot all the
musicians had what was called
cartage and what cartage was is let's
say
um i took four of my guitars
my amps and then there's this guy and i
brought it to a place
where somebody's gonna take care of the
instruments right
and then all i have to do is call them
up and go i'm gonna have a gig at the
whiskey
have my whole rig set up at six so this
is interesting
so none of the guys in la had to carry
their stuff so
and this guy named bob bradshaw who is a
key
uh bob bradshaw uh is the genius he's
still around it he used to build like
steve lukather's
rig eddie van halen's rig but remember
back in the day it was you know
400 rack mount units of guitar effects
and two full marshall stacks and so even
the locals
were doing it because they can you know
cartage wasn't that important so
if you had a recording session you just
call up i want my gear here
and uh have the strings fresh stretched
intonated so this the say i had a gig at
the whiskey i'd just drive to the
whiskey
show up my gears there and then i could
leave because the cartage is gonna
take my gear now now that's different
from new york
well new york we don't have and we
didn't have anything like that so
new york bands uh or musicians would
take their smallest amp they could
a guitar a couple pedals because they're
taking a cab to their gig
okay what they could carry so um it's
like um
even looking like the steely dan albums
that's the new york sound i mean they
have their own sound but that's like
so here's what happened in the 80s is in
massachusetts where i
i was an m the l.a scene
you if you wanted to be like the bands
on tv you had to like invest
in these tall rack mount gear things
the marshall stacks and you know but the
only difference is like they wanted it
so bad to copy
the uh the scene that they'd have to
bring this stuff to gigs
um because we didn't have carnage and
everybody gets to the age where you
don't want to
carry all that crap yeah um but you know
i
i have friends that like you know
there'll be six amps on stage
major pedal boards are like you you you
took that to a gig at a college
well i didn't i told the cop so part of
the sound is
you know they say when with the reverbs
and the choruses on guitar if like you
listen to the
clean parts and they sound really jangly
and shiny
almost keyboard-like and then the leads
had
let's just call some wetness on them
which is some reverb
chorus which modulates the sound a
little bit like the frequency just a
little bit
well we started to chalk that up to the
la
sound and so if i went to a gig and had
a sound
in new york they'd be like oh so you're
like you sound you have an la sound
but the big thing is it was bob bradshaw
and
the fact that they could pay him to
build this monstrosity of a rig
which was fantastic but they didn't have
to carry it so
it became an la thing that like the
sessions were there the cartage would
drop the stuff off
but here of a session i have to choose
an amp choose the appropriate guitars
and whatever i could fit in my car what
i could get to the studio
so i'm not calling someone up going make
sure the tubes are fine make sure the
guitars are strung up
so um but that's a big part of
the sound that's really interesting too
because
not only is is this cartage providing a
service which then allows the musicians
to focus
on other stuff which could be their
musicianship or it could just be like
living a
hedonistic lifestyle right we're gonna
talk about that in a bit
but it it's also part of what we can
call the
the ecosystem of of
music and even you know heavy metal also
rock and roll there's
overlap within the la scene
which i mean so let me say what i mean
by that
all these other people who are not
directly
part of the production of the music
right you've got the band
as as the producers you've got the
audience
but then you've got all these other
people who are part of the making the
things happen so you know if you're
touring you have a road crew right and
they are they are part of it
um so you know i would say that the the
ecosystem as a matter of fact i'll bring
in a philosophical concept here that
that's taken from
um aesthetics uh more artsy stuff rather
you know
and sort of high art things this guy
james dickey talked about this concept
of the art world that he took from
um art from arturo danto and he
elaborated it more
and he said you know you've got the
producers of the art the artists right
painters or sculptors or whatever
and then you've got this entire penumbra
of people
that are part of the art world
and this includes like the museum
operators this includes the people who
get art from one place to another sort
of like cartage right
this includes um you know the entire
system and so
like the record the record companies
would be part of this
um i would say you know managers uh club
owners
um and this cartage fits in with that
because
it's it's allowing people you know like
you mentioned guitar text right a guitar
tech would be part of that
and by being involved with that in a way
that can allow you to do it full time
rather than it's just something that you
do while you're not
working in a restaurant you're able to
be more involved with that world and
there's like a feedback loop that takes
place the more that you have
all these other people who are doing
these things that eventually lead to
performance by a band the stronger the
ecosystem is
you know yeah oh that's that's a good
point
um yeah and i guess
california or let's you know the l.a
scene
um is more conducive to it why maybe
because
at the time that was where all the
records were or a lot of the records
were made in america
they're they're in nashville boston was
a big scene
but artists like till tuesday the cars
um all these bands that uh boston they
became huge but then they came out
they came out of boston they were a
great club band yeah yeah right and then
they have this new ecosystem that you're
talking about where it's like now they
have maintenance now they have roadies
now they have you know somebody to make
sure their guitar is going to play in
tune every night
yeah well even bands that are making it
on the east coast
in in the 70s are winding up out in
la you know so kiss is all of them are
spending a lot of time in la
um i'd be curious since you you know uh
you know
buck dharma was was louis cult spending
a good bit of time
out there in california you know i mean
they were touring so obviously they were
hitting it
right but they were also touring britain
and you know all sorts of other places
but i wonder if they were spending time
out there
we know the english uh heavy metal
people were spending a lot of time out
now right
especially the established ones you know
um
i wonder i mean they were always a new
york band and
even like i think in the 80s
they uh you know i should ask him this
but um you know he
he lives you know not too far from dc
now okay
you know now bands live wherever they
want but yeah
i think they were i i wonder because
buck dharma actually if
and for those of you uh that um had
guitar for the practicing musician that
magazine
well he used to be a big part of that
publication and he would have guitar
secrets but then
you know that's when buck shaved his
mustache and got the glam hair
and um stopped playing the sg started
playing like steinberg kind of guitars
of of the 80s and he was much more of a
an la type i you know i i can't believe
i forget where that was published
but it was it was a very la thing he was
brushing elbows or meeting and hanging
out with a lot of the la players because
you know they do an issue where they're
all kind of had a round table so
i'll have to ask him if if he ended up
in la in the 80s or if it was just new
york and
he was you know kind of sending the
stuff oh yeah um
but yeah i mean that that actually
points out a really important
feature right so being in la
is sort of like if you're a politician
right you want to be in dc because
you're going to meet everybody
and everybody's like not that far away
from you it's not like
being uh in the midwest and then you've
got to like take a plane and all that
you can't have that day
day in and day out interaction with
right
in your in your chosen field and this is
part of what we you know
when universities work which is not all
the time that's part of the idea behind
a university
is that you're in a place with your
colleagues and you're talking about the
cool stuff that you're
you're into right and it doesn't always
happen that way but it looks like
la was that kind of place in the late
70s and then going on in the 80s
it's interesting i'll mention a story
and then i we should jump back into
talking about some of this this
architecture of the scene
yeah so a friend of mine who's also
a musician he's a bassist uh blitch66 he
he and i were talking at one point about
la and he he went from new york being in
new york bands
out to l.a and then he had an epiphany
because he looked around and he saw all
these people this is like the early
2000s and he's like
they think that this is still the 80s
like they're going to come out here and
they're going to like make it big
in the clubs and they're going to get
signed and all that
and he's like there's there's a lot of
people out here competing for
less and less spaces and he was really
smart uh in terms of business he
actually started his own clothing
company
for these rockers you know so he could
supply them i mean he was still playing
but he could supply them with this stuff
and instead of trying to make money on
the the gigs that would come along
right with a million people trying to
compete with that he would he would sell
them the stuff they were going to wear
at the gigs
you know what that's that's a fantastic
idea because
yeah you're right i mean that stuff i
mean a lot of the people
from l.a uh either went back to
nashville or went to nashville because
that's what
the new scene was um dan huff is a great
example
who is actually dan huff um
is uh as a nashville guitarist a rock
guitarist
you might know him from the band giant
so he was a session player
he played on michael w smith records amy
grant records
and he was the number one call like on
the michael bolton records all that
stuff
he was the number one call up there with
steve luther and mike landau
so dan huff was extremely important and
crazy things like um there's an
alternate version of here i go again
um by whitesnake that dan hoff actually
plays guitar on i didn't know
so dan huff was asked to join because
dan hoff is a monster rock player but of
course he's good a lot of stuff
and he said i remember him saying if you
if if you want me to sound like john
sykes you're crazy
if you want john sykes you get him back
in the van
because you know i'm not going to be the
the guitarist for a white stake but of
course
giant was pretty big his band um
but he's somebody that was in the la
seen he went from nashville to l.a
and was doing all the rock sessions i
mean but now he's been back and
he knew to go back to nashville where
he's still making records he's not
really playing rock so much anymore
um you know yeah i mean i think you can
say that
with the la scene it's not as if music
isn't being produced there
anymore right music is but it but it's
become diffused that that sort of
special
confluence of all these different
factors that we're talking about that
maybe lasted a decade
um it it ended up uh petering out
you know um and
so anything we can say the same thing
you know like the new wave of british
heavy metal didn't
stay the new wave of british heavy metal
forever right you
right of certain situational factors
that lead to the production of a lot of
really great music that can be sustained
so you know when we talk about like the
sociology of metal
we're not just talking about like metal
identity and whether people you know
wear leather jackets or jean jackets or
things like that and we're not just
talking about the sonic stuff which is
absolutely important we're also talking
about like
an economic substructure
that allows these things to to continue
on
you know that that was totally invisible
to all of us as
as kids in the 80s but now we can look
back on and say
yeah that's what it took in order for
that to happen you know
but i remember yeah that you're you're
right and then i guess by the time my
early 20s
and i would um i liked a lot of the la
guitar players
but you know around boston if you played
like that
well we played very different in boston
the new york players play very different
yeah but um i was into that stuff and i
would have
um i actually got called for sessions
for a while
that wanted that sound because i had
copied it so much on the records growing
up and they said well
that the la thing and so i knew what
that meant sonically
stylistically um do you think that do
you think that was partly
also due to like the influence of like
mtv and
huge yeah i mean look i mean um you know
capitol records all those based in
california
uh we all know what the paola thing was
where they would
pay the stations to well you should
explain that actually
i think some some of the people you know
watching this might not actually know
that
so what was the payola so
so uh david geffen
not to point him out uh not to single
him out but yeah from
records um would uh
go into these deals where he'd make
contributions
right uh in exchange for this song will
be played every hour
i have this artist we're gonna push them
and um you know it's kind of done in in
the way where
it was phrased it's kind of like you go
to a college
i'd like to uh invest in your endowment
but i'd also like if my daughter got in
yeah so um that started coming out that
these record companies had a budget and
they called it the payola scam
meaning they paid um and i'm sure
mtv was no different um
mtv imposed a new set of um
matters or constrictions you could say
that i think also led
not just to sound but to to look right
so there were quite a few artists who
just really couldn't make it on on mtv
and
you needed to be like physically
attractive or at least not not
unattractive you look at a lot of those
those um videos
and you know so here's here's an example
of a band that was always
sort of stuck in the second tier and i
don't think could make it
out of that uh grim reaper right
i was just gonna say crib reaper yeah i
mean they're they're good
right um their singer
is just not mtv photogenic the way they
say mark slaughter is you know
or something you know i always think of
that uh
uh what's what's the video that they
used to run uh they had one big video on
there
it was um see you in hell in hell yeah
yeah
and um i remember like you know and
i'm a left-handed guitarist but the
guitarist just looks super awkward
playing left-handed the way he held his
guitar and it wasn't the american flag
guitar
and you know this guy with the messed up
teeth singing high for no reason at
certain points and it's like
it was it was pretty cool but um it
wasn't nice to look at
as far as you know the mtv well look you
know poor christopher i think
i think that had a significant impact i
mean you compare that to somebody like
the guys from rat or motley crew i mean
quiet riot kevin dubrow is just looks
like a troll right
but you know they they had their own
thing going on right
uh i mean van halen they were very
photogenic
um true you know and then you think of
like a band like wasp
um i i watched some old wasp videos
recently and they're very over the top
as music videos were back then
right oh my god yeah but you know they
hold up
um as as sort of a type of art form and
the songs are great
you know and blackie lawless so here's
here's we should
let's let's actually shift a bit so um
some of these bands that we're looking
at
in this they it's almost like they
didn't have a clue what the hell they
were doing you know and they needed
management to
you know maybe they had players who were
not as
involved in trying to you know put
everything together so
you take somebody like jk jake jakey lee
um he could you know he he probably
would have had a better career
had he had somebody to he was a great
player
he is still a great player but he
probably could have used somebody to
open
some doors and to say don't like sign on
with these people
osbournes at certain points or if you're
going to
you know make sure you're getting
something your contract is better
um and i but but some of the the bands
really so let's talk about bands that
fed into other bands
and how it led to success for some of
these
i would say some of the bands that
hardly anybody hears about anymore
sister
uh and you know the the prelude to wasp
in circus circus
oh my god yeah these these are bands
that
people don't really listen to anymore
mickey rat was another great example
right mickey rat had stephen percy and
jakey lee and they're playing all these
clubs
um the early docking early dawkin had um
bobby blotzer and juan crocier who are
going to be in rant later
vinnie vincent invasion would be a
little bit later but
that had uh mark slaughter and dana
strum who are going to be
leading slaughter after they they leave
and i think part of what you see are
these these um
these people who are um
they're learning by being in bands that
are like they're getting close but
they're not making it and then things
fall apart
you know and then they go on to another
band like you know what what are the
bands we're talking about here
rat wasp motley crew also guns and roses
to a certain extent because because
there were
um uh you have izzy stradlin in london
uh bobby marks was was in keele
or it was in london and then he goes on
to keel afterwards right so there's
there's a lot of like training ground
stuff happening i would say
in some of these bands that are part of
the la scene and
you know how are they able to some of
them put out albums but they're spending
a lot of time playing in these clubs you
know yes
yeah yeah i think that that's that's an
important dynamic there that leads to
these these mega
let's call mega bands right van halen's
a mega band
uh rant is a mega band compared to um
some of these you know more middle tier
bands
well it's funny um back to mark
slaughter thing i don't know if you're
aware so the vinnie vincent invasion
um and mark slaughter's uh done a lot of
interviews and you know he was
i guess he i think uh
well vinnie wasn't always so straight
with him but what happened was
something happened uh and the record
company didn't
want to deal with vinnie because
vinnie's the head case or he disappears
or he
so what happened was vinnie vincent
invasion and became slaughter
minus vinnie vincent yeah so what they
did is they took the whole band away
from vinnie
and said we're signing you as mark
slaughter and of course vinnie
lost his mind about it going you know
this is my band or
but you know it's interesting so
um but they had like a contract right
and they they
rolled them into the second part of the
contract is how it went or
i think what it was is like it was
renegotiating
i think they did did they do one records
together or two
all systems go was mark slaughter right
so
um but you know he wasn't
uh vinnie vincent wasn't getting along
with anyone
and um so then that's the last we heard
of vinnie vincent after those records i
mean he was
far out of kiss yeah he became a
reckless right and
um you know it's interesting hearing
these guys talk about you know
i bought you know like uh gene simmons
or mark slaughter or whoever
talking about walking down the street
and bumping into someone
you know and for us if you remember it's
like you know there were posters on our
wall you don't bump into anything on the
road
you know yeah um so um
but yeah although with some of these
bands in the
early 80s like say wasp or
motley crew if we did run into them and
they didn't have their hair all
pushed out and they weren't like wearing
the outfit and they didn't have the
makeup on
we might not recognize them we might be
like that guy looks familiar but i don't
you know whereas like if it was iron
maiden
you know if you ran into bruce dickinson
or adrian smith or
you know clive burr you'd know
immediately who they are because they
never
they looked exactly the same spandex you
know
um uh i i was gonna
i was gonna make another point too uh
with that about slaughter
um oh i know what i was i was gonna say
so yeah
you're bringing up with something so
interesting and maybe
um we can say is contributing to an la
sound is in that that is
you've got these people in this band
then they go to this band then they've
gone to this band
now like i said about uh musicians it's
like
jakey lee um you know in the early 90s
did that band badlands but he was
starting to play different
but uh every time jake did something i
mean he's bringing his signature sound
yeah um that's gonna be on a record and
of course like
if any van halen went through different
bands well you'd have that sound
consistent
so we have the carnage that i was
talking about before we have the
community where they're
inviting each other to listen to their
stuff they go to each other's shows
and they go wow that was quite well
whatever he did and they might be like
well what's that effect well bob
bradshaw built mine
well maybe bob bradshaw built mine too
so now you have
sounds that are sonically um
similar yeah and the trends were
different there than say
boston i mean boston was a huge
for all these clear axis avalon uh
paradise uh the channel i mean we had a
million
and even if you were even if you weren't
signed but you were a killer band
it'd be lines out the door to go see the
band but the thing is
the scene um like you had mentioned so
like sociological it's people act
different on the west coast in the first
place
yeah so that's that actually leads into
another thing that i
hadn't put into our notes but i was
thinking about
earlier today the lyrical content
of la stuff now i think this is where we
do have to bring up that that weinstein
distinction between
you know whatever we want to call it the
more the more
glam uh stuff and then
the more sort of middle of the road
traditional heavy metal power metal
kind of stuff because if you if you
think about like a band like
rat motley crew
let's put docket in there as well the
bands that are more
glammy there's a lot of stuff about a
sort of hedonistic lifestyle we're going
to party a lot you know now you've got
that also with like kiss right
uh you know uh all sorts of stuff wasn't
doing it
kiss just talked about it exactly yeah
yeah
and then you've you know you've also got
like themes about
um you got love songs right are that are
mixed in there
as well uh power ballads uh and then
you've got you know more straight ahead
um metals you know like like um
you know i mentioned in our top 10
you know we could talk about um
armored saint right or syria ungul
where it's more fantasy oriented or war
oriented
some other bands that would kind of fit
in with their leather wolf a band that
never unfortunately made it that big
um st vitus is doom metal they're coming
out of la so
i think you've got almost like a you
know like so
for example iron maiden not a lot of
love songs in there
even not a lot of partying songs right
no
not a lot of songs about like yeah we're
gonna you know stay up and drink all
night
maybe do some blow and you know uh have
a lot of sex or stuff like that
that's more of a of that that mainstream
kind of thing i mean
you could also say with like ronnie
james dio i mean half the time you're
not even sure what his lyrics actually
mean but with with a band like you know
poison or motley crew
or rat the sexuality part is way way
more
in your face and it's late right so it's
a very hedonistic place we're gonna
we're gonna drink a lot we're gonna
screw a lot we're gonna
have a great time maybe throw some tvs
off the balcony
or something like that you know i think
that's that's
what do you think is that is that part
of the la it's not part of the la sound
uh no you're right part of the lyrical
content the ethos of what
what you know what what metal is about
you know
well i think you know if you actually
that's a great
uh that's a great observation because
let's go back to sunset strip
you know you went there you would play a
show everybody's drinking partying and
then you go to the rainbow and drinking
party
and then you know they were you know and
it's warm 20
uh uh 12 and you would and i would guess
too you'd probably dress up for it too
right oh you know you're dressing in a
certain way
you're not going like in a suit and tie
you know i'm going to listen to a bit of
uh up and coming music yeah and
everybody went to be seen
and you could do it like you know in in
our climate
you can't you know uh you know it's cold
half the year or it's not
yeah but it's comfortably in the 70s
there
so i think climate might have something
to do but it's year-round that you can
go out
and as far as yeah i mean look um
the anthems made a big back to quiet
riot uh
mental health you know and like anything
you could pump your fist to
go yeah but remember this was not only
an era of
um the sexuality and everything but it
was
if you were if you pay attention to just
the culture of the country was
it was the kids against the parents and
it was
like the movie footloose like the
breakfast club like all these movies
in in the 80s were all about you know
but like that was that was literally
through the music too you know like um
we're not going to take it
i was just thinking about we're not
everybody yeah yeah
and um so they tapped into this whole
it's not a party thing but we're all
just together
and we're going to fight the people that
want to censor us and we're with you and
you're not by yourself
and we're the outsiders i mean look at
rant out of the seller right
um yeah right and the those videos right
they got the rich people
and that you know like milton berle in
one of the videos right oh i can't stand
this noise you know that's right that's
right
yeah oh yeah of course what do you want
to do with your life
you know the whole thing is i want to
rock and it's like in your face and it's
like you're the stuffy old man
that there's gonna stop on my dreams and
um but that was a big theme i think
in in our culture in the 80s you know
and of course let's not forget about the
whole chipper gore
you know warning label where he had all
the hearings with frank zappa and d
snyder and
i mean yeah the 80s was all about like
you know it's interesting to go back and
see the debates in the 80s on tv
and it kind of was like that in real
life it was like that in life we're
going to call this all
art in the form of movies in the form of
music
and a great outlet i mean look you know
kiss in the 70s probably started the
anthem with rock and roll all night
you know yeah and it's kind of like big
chat around to it
but they're probably the only band that
if you well
you know this this is a bit of uh
i just thought of this but this is
something that andy and i have talked
about quite a bit when we watch nfl
football you know
when you watch football today um you're
going to hear all sorts of metal songs
in there like crazy train
crazy brain and you think i i'm always
struck by that every time that that
happens i'm like
wow this has been so co-opted because if
if somebody had played something like
that
you know in a uh any any sort of
sporting event in the 1980s
all the old people would have been like
throw that bum out of here you know
and now it's like well that's just
background music you know
um you know like we're the demographic
we're not gonna
you know now we're the the older people
but that's we actually grew up with that
whereas at 1982 you're talking about
people that were like listening to
music and say the 40s and 50s yeah yeah
um so like you know they would
definitely have
um uh or there there was a big there was
a big
among our parents generation there was a
big like 50s
60s nostalgia you know we're going to
listen to all that
you know whatever you want to call it uh
kind of music but not this new stuff
this is you know i remember actually
when i was a kid um
people would ask me especially in my
family why do you listen to that stuff
that's so angry
you know and i'd be like well it's not
angry yeah
and you know it's funny because i have
this joke you know
people always ask you when you're
stressed out or do you meditate
well i don't because if the mind's quiet
it starts racing and
but you know what is meditation if i
take an iron maiden album and turn it up
and lay down
it's um it's calming it has a calming
effect
you know i used to go to sleep at night
my go-to
tape was a double-sided you know
45-minute tape
and it had the scorpions blackout and
the scorpions
uh love it for a sting on each side and
there's something about
i mean you know rudolph scheckner is a
really really great um
composer when it comes and a really
great guitar player too yeah
and there's something there was
something about it that would i wouldn't
like automatically just
drop off to sleep immediately but like
sort of like wrapping my mind around the
what was going on in the song would
would lull my mind
and i would be able to sleep yeah and
it's not
i don't hear aggression it's like you
know something interesting i always
liked about dawkin
is you'd have these very busy guitar
parts like chicka chick
and the band but don dawkin here is
singing these long notes
yeah over this pretty intense like um
kiss of death
right uh from back to the attack the
first tune
super heavy guitar riff you know um very
busy
and then he comes in singing these long
notes over it
which is kind of a dreamy thing but um
it's kind of like i remember my 16th
birthday party somebody bought me
anything mom seems trilogy
and i put the record on immediately and
my friends who hated metal were like
this just makes me want to bang my head
and i'm like
this is actually having a comment on me
you know and i'm like well
bang your head yeah but
andy says andy says i have nostalgia for
the 80s more and more as i age and i'm
more happy
as a person now that's that's
interesting that's really cool
a lot of times nostalgia is something
that people
feel more as their lives
suck more right they look back to the
good old days you know or the glory days
or something like that
and i think there's a different kind of
nostalgia
that's felt on the part of people who
kind of have their life together
and are gender generally happy and i
think it's different than that kind of
like pining
nostalgia that where people want to live
in the past
i think those are two different kinds of
nostalgia you know
absolutely yeah i mean the napoleon
dynamite
if you've ever seen that uncle rico you
know always talks about how the coach
should have thrown them in in 1982.
if they just threw me in you know we
would have gone i would have been famous
and
but it's funny because the setting is in
the early 80s except for
except for that there's an internet so
you have his nostalgia where he's still
he's still saying if this just happened
uh
but then the nostalgia of um now with
music
i say this to myself a lot and i'm glad
andy you brought this up
um so sometimes i'll put on a record
let's say from the 80s let's say dawkin
and
wow this is like better than i remember
it or you know really stood the test
time but then also
are we equating it to a simpler time in
life you know before
we had bills and a mortgage or whatever
um is the nostalgia um
or are we looking back i i find albums
time machines
yeah i i think it can be there can be a
couple different things going on i think
sometimes
you're right that there is like this
nostalgia for you know back when i was
in middle school or high school
but you know from conversations that
we've had
those weren't great times in a lot of
ways you know
there was a lot of i would say
loneliness and
antagonism and i mean it kind of makes
sense
when you're you're an adolescent you
don't know who the hell you are and
you're trying to figure all these things
out and there's people who are mean to
you
and you know of course right but um
maybe those records are the ones that
were there for you these are
yeah you always talk about metal being
the genre for that
yeah for me it was and me too
um i think i think that that aspect is
is right and i think
there's also a kind of looking back
that's
possible as an adult much later on
where you're not just sort of like going
back to your
childhood you're hearing this stuff and
it is old but you're hearing it in a
contemporary way when you say it stood
the test of time i think that's the
experience you're talking about
you're judging it from a present
perspective
um because there are some where you
listen to it you're like oh i can't
believe
i used to listen to that because that's
not very good at all
there are some bands like that but but a
lot of it
is a lot of it's pretty timeless i mean
it is all the time
that's kind of interesting too it is of
a time it comes out
with these bands it comes out of la in
the 1980s
it probably couldn't have happened the
way that it it did
in the 1990s or the 2000s right
it wasn't ready in the 1970s for these
these things to happen like this
um but it it it produced something that
will last for well i'm imagining that
they're going to be
some of these albums are going to be
listened to by
people 100 years from now
well you know we listen to music from
hundreds of years ago we listened to
music from the 60s and you know
something nice i wasn't around in the
60s but you listen to the beach boys or
something
and um you can almost picture
um what it must have been like you know
i mean they were kind of the party band
of their
their era right it was kind of like yeah
but i think
um with the 80 consider everything when
you listen to it like you know
this was during the era where this was
going on this is before
these incidents happened in the world or
before
los angeles became this you know when
you put a record on i
i i always say it's a time machine or a
snapshot of that time
that um can't be reproduced they they
wouldn't have written
back to the attack now there's no way
right right
because if you don't know everything
i'll add one more thing to this and then
we should take any any sort of uh
questions and and wrap up um
[Music]
you're right it's it's it's a time
machine going back to a particular time
but it's it's also going back to
people who no longer exist in many cases
um you think about like uh a motherhood
album
right um they're all gone all
three of the original guys and yet we
can hear
this legacy that they have left behind
and it's a pretty complex intense legacy
you know and in addition to the albums
we also have like you know
uh youtube videos of performances that
they may have done
whether it was on a tv show for example
they the young ones right motorhead
actually did aces fades
in one of the episodes or like um
concerts or
or things like that and then all the
interviews with the these these people
who are
uh doing it if those are recorded ronnie
james d is another prime example you
know
he's he's been dead now for over 10
years i think
there's something of him that that
definitely
lives on in the music and it's it's very
difficult to describe
what what that is but we keep it alive
by
by re-listening to it you know you know
exactly no i i agree
and um yeah with dio's case um
yeah you put it on it's like you know
that's him at that moment
that whatever happened that day for the
recording or the vocal take
and um you know we call it an
album but it's kind of like a photo
album but
shots taken at that at that time
that preceded the you know two albums
later he was gonna do something he
didn't know he was gonna do so that
to me it's it's very uh it's kind of
important
that we put into perspective okay so
this isn't just
a song there's things that went into
like performances
like even if the performance isn't a
good one
you're glad you saw it in a sense
because well you saw you witnessed
something
maybe they didn't sleep the night before
maybe two of the members are in a fight
in this case or maybe
yeah yeah have the right food from the
back for them backstage or
so even every performance has to do with
you're going to get
even if it's the same set list it's
going to be different in some way
because
we're people that's an interesting term
witness
right witness is something fuller
than just perception than just
like say hearing something there's
there's more
involved and i i don't have any way of
like saying exactly what that is
at this point in time but i think that's
that's an important term
um i mean we should probably do a
session specifically at what's what's
going on when we're listening to
something
from 1976
and we're doing so in in the present you
know sort of like
breaking down what what that that is or
could be or mean
uh but for for those of you attending
any any
questions comments before we wrap
up for this uh session nine
anything that you want us to address or
okay to come off mute sure yeah um
i'm just going to comment on the use of
the word witness as well because what
struck me as you were talking about it
is this idea that we have
you know kind of a craving we've talked
about this in other sessions but to be
seen
to be acknowledged to actually be able
to bear witness to the
thing that makes us you know part of
this community but also
doesn't limit us by definition of being
involved in this community
and i think that that's something that
i've always really appreciated
is that flexibility to kind of move in
and move out
um there isn't really at least you know
at this age we should hope not right
because we're we're middle life um
this idea of like you know kind of
pointing out who is or isn't
authentic anymore but the ability to age
is part of the movement and you know
when i hear
and i keep coming back to priests
probably just because i've seen more
pre-shows than
anyone else but you know what his voice
does
now is incredibly powerful for his
age it's also reaching into the past
because there are approximations of what
he was able to do
at like the height of his vocal power
whenever that might have been
but there's not an apology for what's
changed and there's not this like desire
to actually kind of like
exactly recreate it we accept that we're
getting
you know we're getting him now but we
also have the past to call upon and it
brings everything kind of
into this really nice space of
integration
and i don't think that there's a lot of
you know
there's not a lot of opportunity to do
that perhaps with some of the other
bands it's really those powerhouse bands
um even bands i'm not particularly fond
of have done that you know but i think
it's just this idea that you can
you can provide that witnessing and you
can provide that sense of belonging
and connection throughout various stages
of your life and so it becomes enriched
by that
and deeper and a better more
[Music]
sustaining sense at least for me as a
listener but also as a participant in
both the recorded and the live
experience the fact that i can still
see you know priest or maiden or
whomever
like it it's just this moment of kind of
excitement
but it's not the same excitement that i
would have felt were i there in the 80s
right it's just very different oh yeah
you're at a different age you have a
different like you said in your comment
right
um you're experiencing it um
with your experience in life you know
age is not just a number
ages you know uh are war wounds or
whatever and
you as a 16 year old girl might have had
a different experience
uh than maybe you do now if if that
would have been
rebellion you know in 87
is not what i'm experiencing now but i'm
able to call upon
the girl i was in 87 and have an
appreciation for her and an affection
for her
and at the same time just kind of feel
really cool about it all like that's the
best word i can use it's just it's fun
and it's also something that helps with
self-acceptance because you kind of look
at that person and say wow
you know thank god she had these outlets
to like
help herself through the challenges that
went from 17 to 49.
um well this is a fascinating point you
bring up i didn't even
um it didn't even occur to me to think
that yeah part of it is revisiting
you in a different part of your life and
integrating those
reintegrating going like oh when i was
17 and and
i have a better take on me is 17 now
than when i was 17.
if that makes sense totally i i didn't
even think of that um
that angle it's it's it's it's actually
you're you're saying something
amazing it's uh not just the music
you're visiting you might be revisiting
you
at the time so you're when that was
recorded you were 17 or i was 17.
and um everything that was going on in
the la
scene for whatever wherever we were is
in that recording somewhere
exactly not to get too out there but uh
these are things to consider i love that
yeah i think i do the same thing i think
i remember
i i could go back to remember how i
thought what my view of things were and
how they've changed so much and now
listening with the ears of
my age as opposed to 17 is
um widely different but it does bring
the nostalgia part of bringing back to
who you were i like that
in a way too the the the musicians are
a bit more available to us because we
can learn so much more about them so
like think about motorhead right so
again all three of the founding members
are are
passed on and you know rightly so the
band that's left said we're not going to
try to capitalize on this and make a new
motorhead or anything like that right
right um and when we heard motorhead you
know we're like listening to
albums or or tapes or stuff like that
and if we're lucky maybe we got to go to
a show i mean andy and i didn't get to
see actually see motorhead until
just a few years ago um we never saw
them in the in the 80s
but um you know
you can there's so much available out
there
in terms of like think about youtube and
interviews right you can if you
wanted to see what lemmy was like and
what his thoughts were on things you can
watch
um video after video after video
and you can kind of like get to know who
the band was and what was going on or
you can like
read about the backstory of what was
going on stuff that just wasn't
available to us
at the time you know they were kind of
like bigger than bigger than life
um yeah andy says seeing them with mega
death was a whole strange story of its
own
that's that's when we we saw them that
was quite a show
well we probably should wrap up um
so thanks again to scott for for joining
me and particularly for contributing all
that that you know
uh knowledge about the sound itself and
all those components about it i think
that's
that's very important um thanks to
everybody for
for tuning in and we'll we'll pick up
some
we'll probably come back to the la scene
down the line
uh but we've got to move on to others
later on exactly awesome thanks so much
greg for having me
oh you're welcome
you